hello and welcome to part six of
fundamental investing with the use of
programming where we left off we had
just added in
this uh second screen of screening for
not only the priced book ratio but the
peg as well
um originally uh really we had quite a
few that met the price to book ratio but
didn't meet the peg of a minus one but
above zero
and i definitely don't want to change
peg to accept anything above one
but i thought it might be interesting to
look at anything that was [ __ ]
or below one so
anything below one pbr anything below
one peg
uh five years and sure enough we got a
few more we got aig
with a .74 price to book ratio
and then at 0.95 peg
um and we got bank of america citigroup
anybody noticing a trend anyway
then we got uh e-trade just
barely meeting price-to-book ratio uh
but quite a low peg
um then we got lake mason i think
uh with those numbers not too
attractive in my opinion the nasdaq omx
same thing not super attractive rsh for
radio shack which we found before
obviously they're sony
a decent price to book not the best
looking peg ever
and then also xl for xl group
um not a bad looking one i guess anyway
so basically all i was trying to do is
just give us a little bit more options
so we can actually continue through this
tutorial series
eventually we could run the screener
against like i was saying before maybe
the russell 3000
something like that and get even more
stocks and stocks that match
uh better numbers that we would be more
likely to uh
want to value invest into because yeah a
lot of times value investing is going to
be in stocks that
aren't in the s p 500 mainly because the
stocks in the s p 500
um aren't going to show promising growth
prospects you know they're just more of
like a safe
haven almost for money or something but
still
you can find options for value investing
in the s p
so anyway i'm going to close this out
now and the other thing i think we
should do now is now that we get those
two numbers
maybe we won't put a limit on it but the
next thing we want to look for
is the uh p e ratio forward p e ratio
um so generally what you want to look
for is something with a
a decently low p e ratio uh bank of
america actually
with 10.6 i think normally uh the number
you're looking for is about 15
something that's trading at 15 times
their earnings um because basically this
is
this is price to earnings right so what
are their earnings and then
um or i'm sorry we're looking at the
wrong number this was the 40 pe
we're trying to look for a trailing pe
right now
which the trailing p like currently
where are we at
it's trading at 31 times earnings uh but
you could look at the forward pe
which obviously it looks like we're
expecting some growth
it's only trading at 10 times the
forward earnings that we're expecting
for
you know basically december 31st but as
far as the trailing p
is concerned um which i believe is
12 months it's trading at 31 times so
so i i guess you know the numbers that
we you really you know this is expected
you know forward p e
same thing with like p g five year
expected these are expected numbers
so they're not really set in stone yet
like a lot could change
um so you know expected earnings are
oftentimes wrong almost every time
they're wrong so
so anyway especially like five years out
you know peg's definitely kind of
risky when you're out it's not so bad
but anyway enough on that
um i think the first thing we want to
look for is the trailing p e ratio what
is it trading at
right now and for bank of america that's
31 times earnings that's
uh quite high um pretty it kind of
scares me away so
i wouldn't necessarily go for a bank of
america immediately but anyway what
we're going to be looking for is
all the p e ratios or at least trailing
p e ratio
for um any company that meets the other
requirements
so same thing that we've been doing
before um
open up the source code find
uh what we're looking for just kind of
highlight all the way
to that figure and then we'll come over
to our script here
and we've not even begun but uh we'll
define
uh see peg5 was the uh
price earnings to growth for five years
we're gonna call this next one
pe 12 for price to earnings for the
uh 12 months and i almost kind of want
to say like p-e-t
for tran maybe pe 12-t for so we can
remember that it's the trailing version
equals and again this will be source
code.split
and we've been through this a million
times so i'm not going to continue
explaining
and again the other side of it was just
closing table data tags so
there and the zero with part after we
split by that
and that's p12t um the other thing i
would like to say is okay so we got
print stock mutes requirements and then
just since we're
throwing in more data here let's go
ahead and just so we can see it
on the screen when it prints it out so
we'll say price to book
colon comma pbr and it's going to print
out
pg forward five years
and then after that we want to print
a trailing trailing
pe 12 months
and then we're going to print out pe 12
t
so now any stock that is under one price
to book ratio
and and under one uh peg for five years
uh we're going to print all that out and
then also we'll print the trailing pe
we could also specify that only if you
know the trailing pe is under a specific
number
but let's just look at what we get uh by
this so i'm going to save this
and run it and then so i'm going to
pause it while this is running
and then i'll i'll resume once it runs
through all of these
all right it's all done so after running
it we can see that
obviously we've got all the same
companies that we had before
just in case you are you're running this
your yourself and you're seeing that it
says like not available or something
like that
um usually uh i want to say not
available
i mean it could mean something else but
usually not available means
the number is negative as in they
reported negative earnings
so it's not not available i'm not sure
why they do that but
because some companies really will give
you a negative and then but most of the
time it says it's not available
so just keep that in mind like there's
no reason to like look into it very
deeply because that is it's a negative
number
um so looking through the list
uh you know bank of america not too
too appealing citigroup not really too
appealing with 16.
uh and then we've got e-trade
not too appealing so it's probably
negative
same thing with leg mason
nasdaq not too appealing with a 17
radio shack not too appealing with a not
available probably negative
sony not too appealing and xl
well excel is the only one that actually
would meet
the requirements of under at least 15
shirley would have to be under 15
so so there you go we really only have
one more
left in this before we might have to
think about it either expanding what
we're
willing to allow or um expanding the
pool of stocks to something more like
the russell 3
000 or i guess the russell 2000 maybe
would be the next step
or the s p 1500 anyway um
so i'm going to close out of this the
only thing i've changed now
is i'm just going to make a shorter
array for sp 500
known and these are just the ones that
we know meet our requirements that way
we're not looking through the entire
s p 500 every time sucking up our
bandwidth
and sucking up yahoo's bandwidth so i'm
just going to save that
in there just to do that
so now the next thing that we are going
to be curious about
is a debt to equity ratio we're going to
want that to be
um really we don't want any more debt
than equity if we're
value investing so we're looking for a
debt to equity ratio that's going to be
less than one so
let's look at for example since we have
bank of america open let me close out of
this
pull up bank america scroll down where's
debt to equity
total debt to equity it's a negative
possibly because again
all right so not available possibly
because it's a negative
um total debt yeah so here we go you've
got total cash
total cash per share and then your total
debt
so yeah they're probably running a
negative debt to equity so they're
throwing it not available
let's look at another one citigroup and
just see and then we'll look at
excel real quick just to spark some
curiosity so again
uh here i'd be kind of curious why it's
throwing us a
not available here as well um let's see
if if we even have a number for excel
uh because all these guys are throwing
it okay that's equity here
14.88 so there you go um
they've got quite a bit about 14 times
the debt that they have equity
so or almost 15 so that's gonna blow xl
right out of the water for us and
make it a non-good investment but anyway
in the next video i'll show you guys
at least how to add that layer in um we
can also look at current
assets we want that to be twice as much
as current liabilities
uh and then
i mean you could look at the dividend
yield if they're given a dividend
um you want that to be basically
60 or 66 of the
aaa bond yield and let's see what else
we care about i guess we kind of care
we want to know about earnings growth
and you want that to be
i don't know at least above five percent
over the last 10 years
so you can look at some of those other
figures as well for the value investing
but pretty quickly we're seeing that
we're running out of stocks just looking
for them within the s p 500
but again that was kind of expected when
it comes to value investing
you're usually not looking for stocks in
the s p uh
for when for value investing obviously
we can find quite a few good ones for
fundamental investing
so anyway hopefully you guys have been
enjoying this series hopefully i've been
able to help some of you guys out as
always thanks for watching thank you for
your support your subscriptions
and until next time